hey it's evan i just got a new tv it's a
panasonic 55 inch vieira and i'm going
to try to set it up and install it
we'll see how it goes
this was a huge
box
that was impossible to get in and out of
the car
so
not super heavy but just
awkward
now
i need a knife to open this hold up
i was going back and forth on tvs
because
i wanted something
that was sexy
and for that i wanted
a silver frame
thin design
and something that was
big enough to have all my shows and have
some fun so it's 55 inches in panasonic
and let's see what this thing looks like
next up is i gotta get a actual media
unit to put this thing on
but this is a good start
so
this is huge
i think what i'm gonna do is put this on
the floor
and then pop it out
because i cannot lift this thing up by
myself okay on the foot
i got it out
but i don't know where the stand is i'm
gonna have to find it
before i try to put this up for great
all right
this is looking good
ah the stain
now what goes into it
i don't have a screwdriver
i can't screw in my tv without a
screwdriver
i am going to try
with a knife
it's my 55 inch 3d led tv brakes
because i don't have a screwdriver
i'm going to be pretty upset
it worked
i hope
ah the instruction manual
should have read that before starting
all this right
so i still need to get
an official media unit when i'm gonna
place here but until then i'm just gonna
use my coffee table it's enough to get
started right now i'm watching shows off
of my laptop so this is gonna be a big
improvement over my laptop
this is more than a one-man job
this is an expensive tv
that the pieces have to fit exactly on
the ridges here
uh i don't want to drop this thing
nina everybody
so lift that side
so
this is 55 inches
why i love it is that it's super thin
it's less than an inch inch inch less
than an inch thin it's got the silver
border all the way around it's got the
silver frame
this is actually bigger than my coffee
table so i definitely need to get
something
bigger i need a unit here
but uh
i like
let's hope this thing works now let's
see if we can turn it off it's getting
hot
okay
next
power
oh there's another stain here
maybe it's supposed to go on this stand
oh and 3d glasses
this is a 3d tv we've got two pairs of
complimented glasses so see how that
works right
and
this is our plug
okay
this stand i have a feeling could be
very important
hey there's more screws
okay okay
ah
i'm not entirely sure what's happening
so
hopefully by sharing with you guys
i don't drop the tv
and we can see what's happening
can we see this slow yeah this tax stand
came
with the tv
and because i'm a typical guy i'm not
reading the rulebook i have to figure
out how this works without breaking my
tv so this seems to fit
nicely on
top and there's holes
and there's screws
and you would think that the screws
would match the holes but there's
nowhere to actually screw it in
so let's see what happens
i've got four screws
i'm pretty sure it's supposed to go on
like this
it looks like it fits really well
but
where are the screws
they should make these things easier
right user friendly give a good
experience
for your customer where's my knife
screwdriver
taking a shot
educate a guest
oh this is gonna be a while
it does fit okay so this is the right
screw it's the right hole
just a matter of getting in there with
my fingers
to pop that in
i'm so hungry i need some food
i have with me
let some show you we got some pasta
broccoli bok choy
and chicken
healthy meal folks
back to work
aha i got one working
okay i am fairly confident that these
screws go in these
holes because that first one fit very
nicely
so i'm going to try to do the other
three and see what happens
this thing still pops off though
i don't think you need this
this is just decoration see these screws
hold the tv in to the stand
and then this just pops on top
so i was making mike harder on myself
probably because i didn't read the
instructions
but that's okay we won't tell anybody
it's a lot easier without this crazy
plastic thing in the wood
okay i've got it all set up i hope
we're gonna get some power to this see
if it turns on
i cannot find where to plug this in
okay it's plugged in
time to turn it on
see a little red light i saw something
flash
what's up
oh there we go
hey now
that's looking good
okay how do you use this
thing oh
english
canada
home use
we're going to connect it to
our internet i think i have an ethernet
let's see
okay plugged in my ethernet
it says it worked next
we use cable satellite or fiber optics
not yet
congratulations all right
okay
now let's see if i can get online
so let's try to load up
all right
it's pretty complex right it's kind of
crazy
brand new tv and the software is not
date classic
class a
software update was successfully
downloaded oh missed the message that
was great
yeah the right light is on oh here we go
system is initializing please wait tv
will shut off and restart automatically
do not turn off until after the tv
restarts max three minutes
not a great first experience
but we'll see what happens
all right
it's working
so let's see if we can get online
i just want to get online people
let's go into web browser
okay here we go moment of truth
see what happens
all right
inspiring message from george lucas
we'll leave it on that note the tv is
working i still gotta get set up here i
seen a rug i still did my uh
entertainment unit but so far so good
got a tv not watching things on my
laptop anymore
let me know what you guys think if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
below you have a comment you got a
question put it below in the comments
and i'll see you guys in the next
episode